2.5 million years ago we first began to eat
meat.
Prior to that our ancestors ate a vegan diet of berries and flowers and only when early
hominins began to eat more seeds and nuts, therefore taking in higher levels of fat
and less fiber did our bodies begin to adapt to handle meat.
But what would happen if now you ONLY ate
meat?
Without fiber rich foods like lentils, beans,
and broccoli you are going to feel constipated
and uncomfortable.
Not to mention, the simplest way for the body
to make energy is to convert carbohydrates
into glucose.
In the absence of carbs your body will have
to burn fat and break down important proteins.
Creating glucose from protein is known as
gluconeogenesis, and it occurs in the liver,
creating a nitrogen waste that is converted
into urea.
Too much can lead to protein poisoning - which
includes symptoms like nausea, diarrhea, and
potentially death.
It’s even been documented if you ate only
a lean meat like rabbit, which has hardly any
fat, you could eat and eat and eat and still
end up wasting away.
Another potential killer could be the lack
of Vitamin C. Humans are one of the few animals
that are not able to synthesize the Vitamin
on their own.
Without easy access to Vitamin C from fruits
and veggies your body will be unable to effectively
create collagen, a structural protein found
in your tendons, ligaments and skin.
This will put you at high risk of scurvy and
cause you to have poor wound healing, rotting
gums and personality changes.
If not treated you would die from infection
or bleeding.
But eating raw meat could be the way around
this.
The cooking of meat degrades most of the Vitamin C, but raw, thick, chewy collagen rich skin
and blubber of whales can take in 36mg of
Vitamin C per 100g serving.
Way more than the 10mg needed to fight off
scurvy.
This brings us to an interesting case: shaped
by low temperatures and a stark environment,
a traditional Inuit diet consisted of what
was hunted and fished with little, if any,
plant food, dairy products, or carbohydrates.
Despite this, cardiac death rates were half
that of other Americans and Canadians.
How can you be healthy on a fatty diet without
any fruits and vegetables?
You can snack on organ meat like liver to
get your recommended Vitamin A, which is vital for
eyes and bones and Vitamin D (for your bones
too). And Oily fish rich in omega-3 fatty
acids will benefit your heart and vascular
system.
Inuit bodies have adapted to manage gluconeogenesis
by having larger livers and increased volumes
of urine to get rid of the extra urea.
A recent genetic study investigated the genome
of Greenland Inuit and found a selection for
variants that create a protective effect against
cholesterol and triglycerides.
So, it is possible to thrive on only meat
but it’s important to remember that Northern
communities have relied on animal food out
of circumstance and necessity.
Their high fat diet was intended to keep weight
on for days of hunting, and when food was
insecure, not lose weight like modern low
carb diets.
Unless you are planning on eating raw whale
blubber, organ meat, and have genetics on
your side consider sticking to a balanced
diet of all the major food groups.